[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
musical chairs now everybody
[Applause]
No
[Applause]
got three teams to epic dance party
challenges on one grand prize so what
makes you guys that you need never lose
three challenges up to $1,500 on the
line
[Applause]
AJ play my song
tell mr. brand-new show drop that seat
January first and every Friday after
make sure you subscribe and turn on your
notifications so you don't miss a single
minute in the house right now you know
when to come hang with my friends I
wonder what a party is that is right
here
let's check it out that last seat is
your ticket to the dance floor encore
and to get it players wear these mock
looking things as shoes these shoes are
not for racing they're for erasing oh
yeah erasing those lyrics while doing
the running man oh oh it's going down
the first player to do it before the
music stops wins money for their team
but when the music stops if your butts
not in that seat
you get rock alright everybody you guys
ready yeah my man Keita
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the first person race limits will also
get a first shot
[Music]
[Applause]
that was some kind of Awesome raker
Wow
[Music]
[Applause]